Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics.
In the last episode, we talked about the value
of Big Data.
But, as Big Data (and the statistics we do
with it) permeate more areas of our lives,
there are also new problems that come up.
How can we learn from useful data while still
keeping it safe and private?
When there’s SO much data that we have to
rely on algorithms to manage it can we trust
those algorithms?
Today, we’re going to have a discussion
about the potential downsides of Big Data
in our lives and some possible solutions.
INTRO
Let’s start with a Thought Bubble.
This story comes out of a collaboration between
the University of Washington and the University
of California Irvine.
The team wanted to create an algorithm that
could take an image and determine whether
it was of a husky or a wolf.
To do that, they trained the algorithm with
a bunch of pictures.
These images are a great example of “BIG
DATA” that we CAN wrap our heads around.
Pictures are generally made up of millions
of tiny pixels.
And each pixel is made up of three colors,
red, green, and blue.
So three values per pixel is a lot of data.
The algorithm ended up doing pretty well.
The team may have anticipated that it would
recognize the animals’ different body types,
facial features, or body placement.
But it turned out that it wasn’t focusing
on the animals’ appearances at all.
It was mainly looking at snow.
In the data used to create the algorithm,
the research team inadvertently included many
photos of wolves in the snow.
Huskies were often pictured without any snow
around.
The algorithm picked up on that and glommed
onto it as an easy way to tell if something
was a husky or wolf.
Once the researchers learned this, they did
an experiment, feeding the algorithm new images
that had been digitally altered.
According to one of them, Dr. Sameer Singh,
“When we hid the wolf in the image and sent
it across, the network would still predict
that it was a wolf, but when we hid the snow,
it would not be able to predict that it was
a wolf anymore."
The algorithm just learned from what it was
given.
And based on the data it was trained with,
snow meant the image was way more likely to
be a wolf.
Even more than adorable wolf-i-ness.
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
That algorithm brings us to our first concern
with Big Data: bias.
The defining characteristic of “Big Data”
is that it’s big.
It’s too big for a lot of the usual programs
we use to look at data.
In fact it’s sometimes even too big for
us to comprehend.
And when huge amounts of data are used to
create algorithms, we can inadvertently introduce
bias.
Like the wolf and snow problem
Other algorithms could do similar things,
but with higher stakes.
Ones used to determine mortgage and insurance
rates, or assess the risk someone will do
something illegal in the future, might pick
up on things like race or other minority statuses.
And this is real.
Judges in the U.S. use risk assessment programs
while making sentencing decisions.
A commonly-used one is COMPAS, which was created
by the company Equivant.
It basically gives a score of how likely a
person is to commit another crime within two
years.
In 2016, ProPublica published an investigation
of COMPAS.
They looked at the scores of 7,000 people
who had been arrested Broward County, Florida.
The scores were compared with whether those
people actually ended up committing crimes
again within two years.
In addition to other concerning revelations,
ProPublica found, “The formula was particularly
likely to falsely flag black defendants as
future criminals, wrongly labeling them this
way at almost twice the rate as white defendants.
[And] white defendants were mislabeled as
low risk more often than black defendants.”
Equivant, then called Northpointe, did disagree
with these findings.
But, the company’s founder, Tim Brennan,
also claimed that in order to make scores
as accurate as possible, certain factors had
to be included that could correlate with race.
ProPublica cited the examples “poverty,
joblessness and social marginalization.”
So we can’t consider ourselves “safe”
just because we think that our data is neutral.
We should also look for ways to make sure
that the data we use to create our algorithm
is as representative as possible.
If we wanted to build an algorithm that predicted
the success of CEOs, and we ONLY gave it examples
of males who succeeded and females who failed
then our algorithm will have a bias.
We have to supply it with good, unbiased data.
Males who succeeded and failed, and females
that succeeded and failed.
In the tech world, you’ll often hear the
phrase “Garbage In, Garbage Out” which
means that bad input will lead to bad output.
You can’t put biased data into an algorithm,
and expect an unbiased output.
It can be hard to determine what kind of data
will lead to biased decision making especially
considering most of these algorithms are proprietary.
In the Equivant example I mentioned earlier,
the company wouldn’t reveal the details
of the algorithm used for COMPAS to ProPublica
for that exact reason.
It’s also hard to figure out exactly what
an algorithm is doing from the time we give
it raw data, to the time it gives us an output,
or decision.
With the methods we’ve talked about in this
series, like regression, it’s easy to see
which variables they consider important.
But other Big Data methods, like neural networks,
are often way less forthcoming with the “reasoning”
behind their outputs.
While we can’t always tell what algorithms
are doing, some researchers have made other
algorithms that can act as a sort of translator
to turn the complex calculations of another
algorithm into something humans can understand.
The more humans can understand what an algorithm
is doing, the more opportunities we have to
recognize biased data and the resulting decisions.
Some believe that search and social media
websites that use algorithms to affect your
experience based on your data should be required
to release more information about that algorithm
-- how it works and what it’s doing.
That’s called algorithmic transparency.
Privacy is another big concern in the Age
of Big Data.
There’s all kinds of personal data about
you that you might not want people to know.
There are your entertainment choices, like
what you’re reading and how many times you’ve
watched Fuller House or listened to “I Like
It”.
And your school or work--emails, cloud services,
web browsing.
Even your basic information like your location,
your step count, or heart rate are tracked
by your various smart devices.
Companies like 23andMe or Ancestry.com might
even have your genetic code.
Maybe you spend a lot of time at a place with
security cameras.
There are a lot of questions when thinking
about privacy: Who has access to all that
information?
What are they doing with it?
Who are they sharing it with?
And what assumptions are they making about
us with the data they have?
In 2018, The European Union implemented a
law--the General Data Protection Regulation,
or GDPR for short--that addresses a lot of
the privacy concerns people have with the
use of Big Data.
It requires companies that deal with Big Data
to be more transparent about what they’re
collecting and who can see it.
And it might be one of the reasons you got
a LOT of emails about updated Privacy Policies…back
in May of 2018.
The U.S. has The Children’s Online Privacy
Protection Act, which went into effect in
2000.
It’s intended to protect the privacy of
children under the age of thirteen.
The Act basically requires websites and apps
to get parental approval for the personal
information it might collect from kids.
And using that information for targeted ads
is not allowed.
In 2018, a study of about 6,000 children’s
apps was published in the journal Proceedings
on Privacy Enhancing Technologies.
It found that about 57% of them were “potentially
violating COPPA.”
Examples of violations included “sharing
of personal information without applying reasonable
security measures,” “potential sharing
[of] persistent identifiers with third parties
for prohibited purposes,” and “[sharing]
location or contact information without consent.”
Later that year, the attorney general of New
Mexico filed a lawsuit against an app maker
for violating COPPA.
Privacy laws have been around for a long time
all over the world.
But as they pertain to Big Data, a lot of
this stuff is new, we’re still figuring
it out.
At the same time, when universities, hospitals,
and other organizations share data, we learn
a lot.
It can be useful.
A health organization’s survey on risky
behaviors, like drug use, could have incredibly
valuable results to researchers and policy
makers.
So, we can try to make it so that data can’t
be easily connected to the specific person
it came from.
The obvious first step is to not include people’s
names, or other unique, identifying personal
information.
But that may not be enough.
If someone has a rare disease, simply knowing
the city where they live might be enough to
figure out who they are.
One option to combat this issue is to make
sure that there are at least 2 or more subjects
that have the same characteristics.
This is called k-anonymity.
K is the number of subjects who share the
exact same characteristics.
If there are two people with that disease
from that city, we have 2-anonymity because
there were 2 subjects with the same characteristics.
In our dataset, these two subjects are indistinguishable
from each other, which helps keep the data
private.
And the larger k is, on average, the better.
Outside of medical research, there are debates
about what companies should be expected to
keep private.
DNA companies, for example.
In 2018, Joseph James DeAngelo was arrested
as the suspected Golden State Killer.
Investigators found DeAngelo because they
had DNA from a crime scene, which they uploaded
to a public, online genealogy database called
GEDmatch.
The database doesn’t collect DNA, but lets
people upload profiles.
So, the investigators were able to connect
DeAngelo’s DNA with other relatives and
figure out who he was from there.
Even though he hadn’t uploaded anything
to the site personally, the information his
relatives had submitted was enough.
GEDmatch does have rules about whose DNA you
can upload to the site, like you can upload
your own or someone else’s with permission.
Their site policy also currently states that
DNA can be uploaded if it was “obtained
and authorized by law enforcement to either:
(1) identify a perpetrator of a violent crime
against another individual; or (2) identify
remains of a deceased individual.”
And the revelation that cases could get solved
this way has led to questions of how private
companies with DNA databases should be keeping
their data.
Currently, we don’t know how often cases
get solved like this.
Although a spokesperson for 23andMe told the
New York Times that they’ve received “a
handful of inquiries over the course of 11
years” from law enforcement.
He claimed that data was never handed over.
Criminal investigations aside, it’s regular
practice for both 23andMe and AncestryDNA
to share data with medical researchers.
Though participants can opt in or out.
And in 2018, it was announced that the pharmaceutical
company GlaxoSmithKline invested $300 million
in 23andMe for drug development with the company’s
resources.
We have privacy laws in the U.S., but a lot
of this is still ambiguous.
When it comes to your personal privacy, the
best thing you can do is try to be as informed
as possible about what’s happening to your
data when you put it out there.
And all the data out there means there’s
a lot of information that can be stolen.
And yes, better technology DOES allow for
more protections like encryption but it also
exposes our data to wider scale breeches.
Hackers are after your personal information---
information that can be used to set up lines
of credit-- like when Equifax was hacked in
2017.
They also want your photos (remember the iCloud
in hack in 2014)
Your indiscretions…
(Ashley Madison)
Your email addresses…
(Yahoo was hacked back in 2013 and 2014)
Your business files… (remember the Sony
studios hack after “The Interview”)
Hackers have no qualms about cutting off your
access to play FIFA--like when the Playstation
network shut down after an attack in 2011.
Companies and institutions like these that
collect our data have responsibility to protect
it.
But just how much responsibility and what
happens when they don’t.
We’re still figuring that out.
We don’t want to let our excitement about
Big Data to outpace our caution.
We don’t want to be like the scientists
in Jurassic Park: so preoccupied with whether
we could, and not stopping to think about
whether we should.
As a society we need to think about and implement
solutions to the problems big data creates.
We want to use for good not not good.
Thanks for watching. I'll see you next time.